earlier this week the Trump
administration announced that they're
introducing new restrictions that will
make it difficult for pregnant women to
travel to get travel visas to the United
States so if you're a pregnant woman
it's gonna be hard for you to get a
travel visa to the United States
obviously it's very controversial the
White House says it's designed to
prevent women from traveling to the
United States with the sole intent of
giving birth and getting their child US
citizenship yeah
very nicely done but I'm not paying you
[Laughter]
música mágica this is very this is you
know very controversial pregnant women
can't get visas yeah apparently though
the new restrictions are not stopping
people check out this scene from earlier
today at our border are you ready honey
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry I'm sorry that was an absolutely
extraordinary shot that we had there we
need to see that again let's see that
again this is extraordinary yeah
[Laughter]
thank God thank God for the olds 3000
foot umbilical cord it's really helpful
yeah